Joining us today.
I don't think they need introduction,
but that powerhouse team behind state bird and the progress,
uh,
Stuart bureaus and Nicole Kaczynski,
welcome to go.
Okay.
Well,
um,
it's nice to be here for sure.
How many of you have actually eaten that state bird?
Oh,
good.
Like a little less than half.
Perfect.
We're always looking for more
customers.
Probably couldn't get arrested.
Yeah,
well there's that too.
Um,
and it's a long drive from Sunnyvale.
Well worth it.
Um,
well,
uh,
hopefully at the end of this demo that,
you know,
you'll all be racing and coming up with a,
your own programs to hack into a reservation system and,
you know,
get yourself a
excepted
this group.
You know,
I,
that's actually part of the history of state bird is,
is that for some of you,
you probably already know this because like that stuff is important to you.
Um,
but we were in Australia when we were doing kind of a pop up in Australia and I
get a call at three in the morning from Palo Lucchesi who's the writer for the
San Francisco Chronicle.
And I'm like,
wow,
he's calling me.
It's three in the morning,
should I take it?
And I took it and he starts just grilling me about like,
do you know that you've been hacked?
And that people are,
you know,
making reservations.
And then it grew,
it just continued to grow.
So Paolo calls me and you know,
then the BBC calls us,
the New York Times calls us and I'm sorta like,
this isn't a big deal.
People like,
I don't see this as a big deal.
This is not a problem for us.
Like we're okay that people,
you know,
it was like,
it becomes a problem when people hack into the reservation system and then they
don't show up.
Because that's a problem to me is,
is that,
but,
but humans were coming in and,
and they were saying about robots and all this and I was like,
I don't know what you're talking about.
All I know is that we're packed every night.
And that's a great thing.
And it was sorta like,
what responsibility do I have in this?
And I was like,
I have zero responsibility.
Stop being so popular.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
but I,
it spawned off a whole new,
I call it the brave new world of,
of running a restaurant where it's like,
okay,
I'd never thought about that issue.
I deal with like dishwashers,
calling in sick,
you know,
food for,
um,
you know,
real restaurant issues,
a sink that's runny or backs up or something.
I'm never about hacking into a reservation system seems totally out of my
league.
Um,
anyway,
uh,
we,
today we're going to,
we're going to demo something that I think is,
um,
really turned into very much a signature dish at the restaurant and,
mainly because it's so unusual,
um,
and,
and very delicious based on my personal experiences.
Um,
the,
the idea of this is it's carrots and,
um,
we decided to,
to,
to make a carrot dish,
right?
I think every chef in the country is kind of challenged with making a,
a carrot dish.
Um,
something that becomes kind of like part of your,
your,
your roster of,
of kind of,
of dishes.
It's just like everybody's got kind of a great fried chicken dish or a great
steak dish.
He also is a chef,
have to have a great character.
She at least it feels that way.
So our great character,
she's is to do a kind of a carrot for way right where we make a Mochi out of
this.
And you've probably all had Mochi,
but you've never had a savory Mochi.
So,
um,
that's,
and it makes so much sense and I look at it is as Mochi,
our carrot Mochi is akin in a distant cousin to the potato Neil key in Italy.
So it's really like that.
It's that same idea.
Um,
the beauty of it is,
is that it we don't have to use,
we're not using flowers,
so there's no gluten in it,
but we are using,
uh,
starchy glutinous rice flour,
to bind it.
Um,
it's also got a huge margin for error where Naoki are so temperamental and
you've got to have the right starch content in your potato.
You've got to have the right balance.
Timing is such a critical,
these are virtually foolproof.
I mean,
you can,
you can cook your carrot puree the day before and make your Mochi the day up.
Right?
Um,
so there's not a lot of,
um,
there's a big margin for,
for air,
which is always nice.
I mean,
I think even in the home for home cooking,
um,
and it's really awesome with kids.
So if you have kids,
I,
we have a kid.
Um,
of course he doesn't eat anything,
but other people's kids seem to really love this stage when they come to the
restaurant.
As a matter of fact,
we tend to,
when we go on to visit friends or staying with them,
their kids will be like,
can we make Mochi?
You know,
I mean,
they'll ask this and then I'll teach them and we'll do a little like kind of
Improv cooking class.
Um,
so let's kind of get this started.
I've taken the liberty of getting my carrots cooked.
I'm just going to crank this up.
The idea is,
is that I just cooked carrots in boiling water and you know,
organic,
the sweetest carrots you can find.
Um,
just a little salt.
So I'm going to bring this up and they're really tender.
And how you gauge that is,
is do they fall apart in your hands?
And I don't always encourage people to put your hands in boiling water.
But that's what happens when you become a chef.
Come Immune to these ideas of boiling water.
Um,
so these are done now and I'm going to take them and just strain them out in a
calendar
and I want to intensify the carrot flavor.
So this is kind of the trick.
We could stop here and we could just kind of pure a these carrots or we could do
what I'm going to do next,
which is basically intensify the carrot flavor.
Like putting this back on the stove.
Let's make sure these induction burners or is it going?
I think it is.
I feel it.
Um,
Oh yes.
I'm going to add carrot juice to this.
So fresh carrot juice added to these carrots
and I'm going to kind of do it little by little.
So I'm going to like reduce it in and I'm going to concentrate and basically
sweeten up the flavor.
The idea is is to just get the most flavor,
the most carrot flavor into my Mochi.
Otherwise they will just look like orange balls.
But if I can get more in infused more flavor,
it's really helpful.
Okay.
While this is going,
I'm going to kind of roast the carrot.
So as I said,
it's a carrot for way
and so in a pan with butter and don't be afraid to use butter.
Seriously.
You laugh bumpy.
This is why our restaurant is so good.
Um,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to just throw my carrots right into here.
I mean not use all of these.
Try to find some different sizes
and I'm going to take a couple of garlic cloves and I like to keep them in the
skin.
And what I'll do is as I just smash him can just kind of take a knife and I just
want to crack the skin and I want to get just a little flavor that comes out,
right?
And I like to use the skin.
There's nothing wrong with the skin.
Don't be afraid of the skin.
Um,
and I'm going to take some rosemary and I'm just gonna throw a couple of sprigs
of Rosemary in here.
Okay.
A good crack of pepper,
of course.
Like to use a pepper mill.
Just kind of makes sense.
And then,
oops,
pardon me,
the good pinch of salt.
And don't be afraid to use salts.
Hi there.
That's another secret to why our restaurants are so good now.
He can smell that.
Can you guys get that?
Okay,
so soon enough you'll get that.
And I'm going to turn the heat down cause I don't want to roast it too hot,
but I do want the butter to Brown and notice I didn't brown my butter first.
You don't need to.
You can actually brown it in the process of doing it and um,
I'm just going to assume that that's going to be good and keep that going.
Pardon my reach here and notice it.
Nicole just keeps adding more carrot juice to the pot and we keep reducing it
and we're going to make our,
our goal here is this to make like a,
a real tight concentrated kind of blob of a mass.
Okay.
Um,
blob is a culinary term for anything that sort of moves in,
Blah Buehler motion.
Okay.
So these take a while to cook.
You could roast them in the oven or you can just do the whole thing on the stove
top and you see where it gets foamy and buttery there and you see all that.
That's the magic that's happening to the carrots and the,
that's the browning of it and snow.
I just want to manage it and kind of keep it going.
Okay,
cool.
Feeling
free to ask questions as we're going to,
I'm sort of not like save your questions to the end.
Yeah.
It inspires you immediately.
Just like a jolted out.
The only a dorky thing is I have to repeat them for the people who watch it on
the live stream later.
So,
yes,
Andre.
Oh,
do you use a pressure cooker method to caramelize?
Uh,
no.
to answer your question,
but that doesn't sound like a bad idea for the carrot puree to just or,
yeah.
How interested the brown butter.
Oh,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't know.
Um,
I,
I haven't,
no,
but not that.
I wouldn't think that's a great idea.
Do you use a pressure cooker quite a lot for other things?
That's right,
yeah.
Yeah.
We,
yeah,
we do use pressure cookers for,
um,
kind of extractions more or less.
Right.
Also,
I'll throw a whole fish into it,
like whole card and I'll make a fish stock in a pressure cooker.
And it's totally wild and crazy,
but it really extracts all the gelatin is out of it.
I'll do a French onion soup and a fresher cooker where we caramelize our onions
and then we'll put the onions into a pressure cooker with onion stock and then
we'll turn it on and we'll let it go.
And sometimes I'll even put,
I put green air in the pressure cooker with the Iranians and then,
you know,
so it was pretty cool.
I mean,
it's some neat things.
Yeah.
I think that what I like about it is,
is that you,
you don't lose any liquid.
You retain everything.
So everything that goes in is everything that's coming out too.
Right.
Um,
but however,
in this case,
we want to encourage the reduction because we're concentrating.
The sugar is in the sweet flavors in it.
But good question.
Cool.
Those books are just way too big.
You made it to,
yeah,
they're impressive.
It's a lifelong journey through modernist cuisine.
They came out with modern and speaking and I have tacked on many years to my
life to get through that one.
All right.
So,
um,
we're almost there on this making a totally great blob.
Um,
and as it just gets tightened up there,
you can really smell the concentration of carrots and you're just getting such a
nice,
okay.
Such a nice flavor there.
Um,
other mochies that we've done as well,
I think color plays an important role.
So I've done,
we did a caramelized onion and Rosemary Mochi that tasted great,
but it didn't look so beautiful.
Um,
but there's other things that we've done that we have grad great success.
So like a pumpkin or a squash Mochi,
winter squash where you roast and you get that bright,
vivid color.
And then when you mix in the flour,
the Mochi flour,
it,
it works the same way.
And when you cook them,
they look just like the same color of a pumpkin.
So this recipe is totally transferrable to other things,
as,
as many things as you want to kind of try.
Um,
I would totally encourage you to make the carrot version first.
so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to take this and he can see how it's really
tight.
It's lobular if you will clog
with texture and I'm going to,
let's start with that guy.
I think I'm done with it.
I'm just going to puree it.
I want to get it.
I like the texture of carrot in there.
So it's not imperative that it's very smooth.
Um,
but it's,
it's okay if it's very smooth.
I kinda think like the texture of rice,
maybe the coarseness of broken rice is a good way to think about it.
Okay,
cool.
And now what I'm going to do,
the most important steps here is
I am going to weigh it out.
And so
yeah,
basically do,
and you could make,
I mean there is a recipe and it tells you how much to use,
of course,
cause that's what recipe books do.
But basically we like to work in ratios,
right?
And so I've got this nice carrot puree and I'm getting
500 and I know I brought a pound of Mochi flour.
So I start with one to one ratio.
Yeah,
I usually ended up adding a little bit more.
So there's 454 grams.
I'll just go 400 to give myself a little,
and again,
this can totally,
it's,
it's whatever you want to make.
I mean,
we make the US in 2,500 gram batches is kind of the idea.
Um,
and then what I'll do is I've got about 400 grams right here and I'll add,
okay,
another 400 grams or so of Mochi flour
and that'll be my starting point.
Perfect.
And being that I'm adding a lot of
flour,
just a nice pinch of salt into there.
Yeah.
Um,
boy,
2,500.
So that's about five pounds of Mochi,
right?
Well,
we're making two pounds of Mochi.
It would last us about a night's worth of service,
right?
This is one of our most popular dishes for sure.
Outside of the Quayle of course.
But people just love this dish.
It's a hard one for us to take off now because it's so unusual and it's kind of
like,
it's just a slam dunk every day.
People eat it and nobody's like,
oh Whoa,
that's a weird texture.
They're eating it and going,
wow,
I never thought carrots could actually taste so good and this is really unusual.
And that sort of,
it's,
it's that thing that's like,
it's familiar,
but it's different.
And that's one of the kind of the philosophies of state bird is,
is that we try to work within the familiar,
but we want to do something that's just a little different.
Right?
You know,
we do a fried quail in lieu of doing fried chicken,
but the idea was inspired from fried chicken.
Of course.
Right?
We make Mochi instead of neocon.
We do ice cream sandwiches that aren't ice cream ice cream sandwiches that
aren't ice cream.
Um,
but they are at,
they're not,
but they are,
but they're not.
That's an argument that we continue to have.
Um,
we do,
we do things like we do traditional,
this is one of my favorite dishes and it's in the book is we do an a macho
Chiana.
Do you guys know how much Chiana anyone?
You're nodding your head.
I'm going to put you on the spot.
What is it?
You got it?
Yeah,
so it's a Roman dish.
It's a Roman pasta dish that's made with Guan Sharlay,
which is cured pork Gel.
Right?
And so it's got a lot of pepper to it and it's like Penn Chedda but it's using
this portion of the,
of the pork.
It is magic and it's one of my all time favorite dishes ever to be made in the
world.
And it's really kind of a nice tomato sauce.
You start off rendering out your Guan.
Charlie,
you had your tomato sauce and you had Rigatoni and you had lots of pepper,
Pecorino and black pepper.
And that's the dish.
Well,
we do something completely,
we riff off of that and we take one Sharlay we render it out and we had a little
garlic and some chilies.
We had little Chantrelle to it.
We had fresh tomato sauce from fresh heirloom tomatoes.
So this is something we only do in the summer.
And then we use Tofu,
skin Uba as our noodles for this.
So we totally spent it on its ear because I think any anyone's Italian
grandmother would
beat me to a pulp with a wooden spoon in the kitchen if I knew that there was
using,
you know,
I mean,
first if I was using fresh tomatoes in,
in Guangxi,
in Macho Ciana,
you know,
and something beyond just Rigatoni,
but the fact that it's Tofu,
food,
skin,
but it's magic.
And when you eat the dish it tastes like,
and a much a geode.
But it's,
it's familiar but different.
And so that is what we do.
So what I'm looking for here in my dough,
it's just something about this consistency.
It's a little tight.
It's also a little tacky to it,
but it can hold its shape,
not unlike Plato.
Right?
Um,
but there is a nice tackiness to it.
And so for this we would do is we'd make balls.
And so I'm going to have Nicole make some
little mochi balls there.
Well,
I'm going to really put myself to the test because I generally always have a pot
of water going.
Can I do my little tester?
But I'm so confident today cause I don't need to do a test here living
dangerously.
That's something in the kitchen is it's like if we make a sausage or a doe or
anything of that store,
we always make a test here.
We just want to make sure that the seasonings right,
that the textures right.
And so if any adjustments need to be made,
it's not after you've 150 balls and you have to put them back in and re three,
make it.
Um,
so while that's going,
I'm going to turn the heat back on on this.
Okay.
And you see our carrots are just kind of moving away and they're gorgeous,
right?
Not quite there yet.
So we'll just let them kind of finish.
I'm going to turn that heat up.
The next step in our process here.
Ooh,
you know what?
I used
my bowl here.
Um,
let's see if I can do this.
I'm certain we have another bowl for you.
Are you sure?
It's literally right here.
Thank you Sharon.
Okay,
so the next step is going to be to make,
we've got three,
this is the third component is going to be our vinegarette.
And so because we want,
we've got roasted carrots,
we've got pickled carrots,
which I'll go into in just a minute.
And then we've got the carrot Mochi.
We want to reintroduce another fresh component into it.
So this is just fresh carrot juice that becomes the basis of our carrot
vinegarette into that.
What I'm gonna do is I'm going to add fresh lime.
Okay.
I like to kind of massage my lime up a little bit and I'm just going to squeeze
lime juice into this am going purely by taste here.
You guys feel pretty confident that I've got that part nailed
and you know I'm just going to juice you know a character.
So,
all right,
I'm sorry.
A line.
The next,
the microplane comes in handy and this is going to blow your minds.
So I think that micro planes are about the biggest,
the best tool ever to be created in the kitchen.
And I'll show you why
because it can replace everything you own.
All right.
So I use a microplane to grate ginger
and I feel that what I get out of it is,
is I get a great disbursement
of ginger flavor,
right?
And you can see it underneath there and it just,
it really takes it down to such a ground mass.
It works great.
I use a microplane to great garlic.
We'll take a clove of garlic and I don't use a lot.
Little garlic goes a long way,
so you always have more.
This is the mind blowing part.
I use a microplane to great fresh chilies.
And so
it comes with a nice sounds to you're actually grading something and you never
how spicy or chilies are.
Cool.
So I'll add a little bit of ground chili into it.
Um,
I think the Chile thing really blows my mind.
I loved you've never seen that before.
Yeah.
See I'm stealing that.
What we're gonna do is financial,
a,
the fresh black pepper pinch of salt to this.
And then we're going to kind of make an oil slick of extra virgin olive oil.
Stir this whole thing around
and now we've got this like super vibrant carrot vinegarette.
We taste everything.
I think it needs more acid.
The garlic is amazing.
The ginger comes through.
I'm getting a little heat.
I think I kind of want a little more heat in there.
Um,
but this is how we do it,
right?
You know,
you constantly
or tasting for what you want.
I'm going to put a little more ginger in there.
Ginger and carrot is just one of the magical combinations.
So you probably know already
a little more to insure a little more Jalapeno.
What I love about the Jalapeno
by doing this is that you,
you really don't get the seeds.
Let's go fresh spoon.
There it is.
So what I'm looking for there is I want
to taste the carrot juice,
but I want to taste all of the other ingredients,
the garlic,
the ginger,
the Jalapeno.
I want to have a nice little kind of slick of olive oil that can adds the fat to
it.
I also want to just make sure that the line,
the acid and salt is really balanced.
Stripe,
not one should overpower the other.
And that's how we do that.
Cool.
So these carrots are just,
they're doing really well.
And I'm running out of stove space here,
but
we're going to just take it really quick.
So the,
the last part of this dish,
now we've got our carrot juice vin.
This is,
we're going to make the Duka and Duke is just kind of a,
it's a cumin based,
um,
kind of spice blend that we can use in the mortar and pestle.
And we do a pistachio Duka.
We want that nuttiness from the pistachios.
So here I'm gonna let these guys do is turn it up really well.
This is so good.
I love carrots when they're just slow cooked in butter like this.
You see what's happening and we just like magic over time.
It's just happening.
I don't know,
can we?
No.
Okay.
Wow.
You'd have to hold over that cutting board.
Oh.
The camera's not there.
Well it's right there.
It's that one that's right over where your,
yeah,
right there
is how I see it.
Okay.
Can you guys see that?
Yeah.
That's gorgeous.
Wonderful.
Well now that we've got that part out of the way,
ABN just well aware.
Cool.
All right.
I'm going to pull that off and they're going to just continue to simmer there.
Meanwhile,
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to have everything here.
Whole Queue,
coriander,
seeds,
cumin,
when to add sesame to this mix have already pre toasted my pistachios.
I've got Chili flakes and I've got sea salt.
I do not want to toast my chili flakes.
If I did all of you out there would start sneezing,
have eye irritation,
but I'll work over a nice high high heat and bring this up.
And as soon as I can kind of see little wisps of smoke is where I know it's done
and I'm going to place it right into the mortar and pestle.
What other dishes do you find you like cannot take off your menu?
Oh,
well,
aside from the,
the bird of course pork belly.
Yeah.
That pork belly.
Pork bellies,
citrus there.
Saltzman.
Yup.
Um,
so we will have it for dessert
next time.
Next time.
Uh,
the garlic bread with burrata.
Ooh,
that one was transcriptions.
Did it take it off right there.
Um,
we've got that dialed out.
We sell about 70 of those a night and we serve about 200 people a night.
So can you do it?
Good.
That's the one that comes by to late in the meal and you're like,
what?
I ate so much and I have to hit it.
Um,
so the broader that we use is from kind of one of the original burrata makers in
the U S and they're down in La Joya is the name.
Yeah.
I asked him once,
I was like,
so what's your process?
And he was like,
seriously,
that's the one thing I make and I'm going to give you my secrets.
Hey,
you've got a question here.
Conditions.
Oh,
what are some dishes you wish you could that you do?
You constrain yourself.
Sky's the limit.
No,
not at all.
Um,
that's why we have a second restaurant.
Yeah,
there you go.
There aren't really any dishes that we wish we could because Steve Bird is based
around it and it's built around kind of Cook what you are and the freedom of
cocaine.
Um,
the one thing that I always say about our food there is it has to be,
so I wouldn't put it like a steak on a plate and serve it,
right?
It's shareable.
But you know,
there's,
you know,
we've got to keep,
we keep people moving,
right?
We keep the,
the,
that evening,
the dinner service moving and you know,
we want to make sure that it is as user friendly as possible.
All of the,
all of our food.
And we think about that,
right?
How can I get more food on your table is what I think about.
And you think about how can I get more food in my stomach?
Right?
So,
you know,
we're,
it's a team effort.
Okay.
Um,
and it's symbiotic.
Okay.
So do you see these little wisps of smoke and you're going to,
you can see that as I'm,
there you go.
Hey,
you got it.
Okay.
And what I'm doing is the same,
just bringing those flavors out.
Now some of you can smell that.
Just wait,
let's put that back on
when it had some sea salts to this.
Nice Pinch.
I'm going to add my chili flakes because I do kind of want to,
I want them to have a little intensive.
I'm going to add some pistachios to this mix.
Okay.
Now
I hope this works.
We'll you guys share a little bit about the inspiration for the restaurant and
the first place.
It's the so unique.
It's a long story.
It's a beautiful story.
It's a book,
but short,
Short version.
Sure.
Yeah.
We never intended to open state bird.
So we had written a business plan.
We had raised money for what is now the progress and had found a space we're
ready to go and the space fell through.
So we were like,
well shit.
Now we really,
and we found out also we were having a baby,
so like we needed to get a job quickly.
Um,
so we had been focusing on one neighborhood in San Francisco and we told our
broker like,
just look everywhere.
Look in all the places we never wanted to look before.
And a week after our son was born,
she was like,
well,
I have this place on Fillmore,
which I know you don't like,
but thank you.
Should go look at it.
So Stewart across from the panda express that's right across from the panic
express in the Safeway parking lot.
Um,
in addition
a sewer rode his bike down there and walked in to this dark purple grease traps,
smelly,
not very beautiful tiny space.
The whole building was vacant 10,000 square feet.
And then the landlord took him into this space that's now the progress with the
huge arching ceilings from the old movie theater that was built in 1911 and we
were like,
this is where we want to be.
You can be anywhere in the city.
You don't see anything outside those windows,
but you have skylights and just,
it was the restaurant.
We want it,
but it would cost a lot and a lot of time.
And because it had never been a restaurant,
so,
and we needed to make money as we needed.
We needed,
we had a kid now and we were running out of,
out of time.
So we went back that night and said to each other,
what if we take both spaces?
And the landlord was thinking the same thing at that same time.
So we signed two leases at once,
but then had to come up with a new business plan and in a whole new concept.
So in a few weeks we sort of visualize state bird thinking that it would be just
a really fast thing to open and then we can move on to the dream restaurant and
then things unraveled differently.
Funny how that works
in cs.
So state bird and we literally winged it.
That's my kind of chip.
Yeah.
Why American Zen?
Which ps is the best idea ever.
Yeah.
In the early days we used to get that,
like people would say,
God,
why did I think of this?
Nobody has really ripped it off,
which is the trade.
It's,
it's,
there's been a little bit of,
you know,
some people who've adapted certain,
um,
certain ways.
Right.
And I think that that's kind of more the interesting idea.
Um,
rather than ripping it off,
it's actually a lot harder than people think.
And those who have tried to rip it off,
like have had a very tough go of it.
And that's okay.
I mean,
I think that,
you know,
it's,
it's okay to have multiple of restaurants,
but,
um,
it's also really nice and reassuring what we do works because we've really made
it work.
Um,
and that the idea of it came about is during the time that we were looking to
open a restaurant,
we did a lot of private kind of catering gigs,
right.
And,
um,
they were really by word of mouth.
We were caterers out of our little 900 square foot apartment in San Francisco.
And um,
it w w we started to get a lot of requests for people who wanted to have an
informal dinner party,
but still like really creative food and lots of fun and nobody wants to sit
down.
So just like a cocktail party,
right.
And Kitchens,
you know,
nice home kitchens that had a,
a nice little island.
Um,
and it would be kind of a walk around event.
Right?
And so rather than just doing an order of party,
these became like 1112 to 15 item hors d'oeuvre parties.
Right.
So almost like a core stout dinner.
And one of the events,
we even hired a friend who was a Somali a at Gary Danko and he went around and
he just speaks to splashing people with wine all night and talking about the
wine and the food.
And it was super cool and we just,
we had a great time doing this and we were able to take a little more risks
cause you know,
12,
you know when you're serving three or four dishes,
everybody wants kind of like the safe items,
right?
The things that are going to be popular,
like garlic bread with burrata or crab cakes or you know,
but I this particular that really we sort of took it to the next level was we
were serving lamb Tang on toast and doing things that were like,
well,
we built that relationship through the other safer items and people would come
back and it's,
I'd say,
well,
it's,
it's pickled lab.
And you know,
some people I would tell them it was tongue and others I would say it was just
land.
And um,
but it looked good.
It looked beautiful on the plate and we eat first with our eyes.
And I was able to talk people into eating food and the buy in was small,
right?
One bite.
So,
you know,
you've got to think about real estate.
And um,
so we applied that same idea and it really matched the idea is chefs at the time
that we wanted to kind of create a restaurant where we could cook what we want
and have lots of freedom and flexibility and not necessarily have a specific
regional calling,
right?
We're not a northern Italian restaurant.
We're not a Chinese restaurant,
we're not a,
we're,
we,
we've never,
we've always been challenged.
I think a lot of American chefs are challenged thoroughly by how to define
themselves as chefs.
Right?
Like,
well,
what is it when people ask me like what is it,
the food you,
you cook,
it's really tough,
you know?
Well I do as this American dim sum.
It's like California cuisine and you don't really,
you look at our menu and you look at the demographics of the bay area and it's,
you know,
a lot of Asian influence and a lot of,
Mexican influence and kind of like some thorough like American ingenuity it with
some European.
So it's a little bit of everything.
And what I like to actually call that cuisine is this evolved California
cuisine,
right?
Where we're in a state of evolution and evolving what California cuisine really
is to the people who live here and of course were born and raised in this area.
So we,
we have a pretty good understanding of it.
But to answer your question,
we were doing this kind of thing and it just sort of,
we looked at the kitchen that was in the front of the restaurant and I kind of
thought about like ducks hanging in the window and I was like,
wow,
you got cooks,
right.
They're like preparing the food and you enter in,
the first thing you're doing is you're entering through the kitchen.
Um,
it,
it feels that way because the kitchen's right there and the dining rooms in the
back and um,
it all kind of just,
it just made sense and we just put the pieces together and that's it.
Yeah.
It's uh,
and,
and it,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's really turned out to be not just like people would say,
oh,
great concept.
And I was like,
what are you talking about man?
This is my restaurant.
This is not a concept,
you know,
this is our,
like our heart and soul and our passion and our love for cooking and teaching
and interacting with people.
The people who are coming in to have an experience that was different than other
restaurants.
We looked at it,
that we're,
we're all one world in the right.
We get to talk to the guests and the guests get to talk.
And when you know that feeling you get when you're sitting at a counter and
you're watching the Sushi chefs preparing and you're talking and you know,
you,
you create this rapport.
And so it was really imperative to have that for us.
We wanted to know the people we were cooking for two,
we want to have that relationship.
We want to not have it be like dining room,
kitchen separation.
Right?
And we talk about that all the time in front of the house,
back of house.
Well,
it applies to diners as well.
So anyway,
that's kind of,
and it really gave us the ability to do whatever we wanted in the kitchen.
Um,
as long as it tastes good,
looks good.
It works.
So that's it.
All right.
I say,
let's put this dish together.
So our carrots are nice and soft and you can see that just in their shape.
And what I'm gonna do is I'm going to throw some butter into the pan and at the
same time let's drop.
Do you want to drop about 10 of those into the simmering water that's been
salted?
You guys saw me do that.
Cool.
I'm going to take a couple of these carrots.
We can leave them whole but I'm going to cut them up just a little bit.
Oh yeah,
these are perfect.
And then I'm going to take some pickled carrots and the pickled carrots are just
a baby carrot when we pick all the recipes included,
but it's a vinegar pickle.
Okay,
so this is not a fermented pickle.
And what we'd like to do is shave.
I'm really thin you can use a knife for that
or a mandolin,
but if you've got the knife skills,
apply it in a sharp knife.
And that's what I say.
And so the idea of having a pickle in addition like this really makes a lot of
sense.
It adds a nice texture contrast.
It also adds a nice refreshing as civic balance to it for a couple of different
colors.
Here
we do sweeten the vinegar.
So we use for this one is rice vinegar and we salt and a little sugar and some
spices as well into it.
And we pick them whole and then every day we'll cut them,
you know,
we'll take them out of a big pickle croc and um,
we'll cut them just as I'm doing it right now.
So you get this other,
yeah.
I think part of it is,
is showcasing carrots in different forms,
right?
Whole form,
juiced form,
you know,
prepared form and then kind of rounds pickled where we cut in round.
So you get a real good environment,
kind of an environmental scape of the carrots.
Right.
If that makes sense.
Um,
because we didn't want that lacto fermented flavor to it.
So we do a ton of lacto fermenting at the restaurant,
whether it's sauerkrauts or Kim cheese or,
um,
you know,
we'll,
we'll do a deal carrot,
right.
Um,
dill pickles and we do that,
but it does this one,
we wanted it to be sweeter and we want to just,
we wanted the vinegar flavor,
which of course is its own scent of,
of taking it.
Yeah.
Um,
we wanted a brightness to it,
um,
without quite the salt.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
So these guys are done when they float and if you can see what you can,
can we get one of those moving orbs?
Cause they're not floating.
Yeah.
Um,
so just like a Naoki or any kind of dumpling is this that we would take it and
um,
okay.
Boy,
boy,
girl.
Um,
and what I've done here is I'm browning my butter this time.
I want my butter Brown when I add my dumplings to it.
So the idea of browning butter is,
is that he pulls out a nuttiness how do the butter,
right.
Um,
how,
you know it's brown is when it stops crackling,
right?
So all the milk solids of cooked and tightened up and cooked out,
and then you'll start to see like little particles,
which is those browning and that's how you get the brown butter.
Um,
and I have a done a nice low temp so I can hold this for a minute here.
Other questions while I wait for the Nokia Flute Mochi to flow.
Yeah.
Why did you keep the PR?
That's a good question.
He know it acts as like a little shield in the garlic.
Doesn't Brown too fast,
right?
It's Brown.
It's Brown in a nice way.
But way that I actually love eating garlic right there.
Um,
but it,
it,
it acts as like a little shield,
a barrier.
So if you had the raw garlic into the pan,
you're still getting the same qualities of it.
But when I'm slow cooking or long cooking,
um,
I want,
I want that garlic to not get bitter and,
and I want it to caramelize slowly.
So that little barrier is really important.
Cool.
Anyone else?
Nope.
You can do this step and then show them.
Oh yes.
Later.
Right.
So great,
great,
great.
This is another part of that great margin for,
for um,
error and also from an entertaining perspective and something that the team here
at Google has done is,
is that you take them to this and you can actually cook them,
boil them,
and then refresh them under cold water,
rub them in a little oil and put them in the fridge for later.
And then when you're ready to go,
you can take them right out of the fridge,
put them into your pen with brown butter and just kind of slowly Cookham and
reheat.
Um,
so that's another great thing is,
is that you can do a lot of this ahead.
And so now that these guys are floating,
you can see they just kind of come up like any jump playing.
I like to think these are like our carrot and Matsu balls,
right?
Um,
I'll just take a slotted spoon and I'm just going to place him right in.
And like
the carrots,
I love all that brown butter.
Okay.
So when I add a little salt,
good crack of pepper to it.
And what I'm trying to do is,
is I want a brown these off of it
a little bit.
They look so good.
We'll go on high.
Yeah.
You serving for Superbowl Sunday?
That's a good question.
You know,
every year is like the kitchens they team up and they should,
they should go opposites I guess.
But they do team Alpha and we got to between state bird and the progress and
they do a huge Superbowl Sunday spread.
It's kind of insane.
But for family meal but for family meal,
yeah we do like we don't,
you know,
yeah.
Our menu's won't change.
They have fun make like chicken wings and yeah,
we'll start seeing like Thursday and Friday I'll start seeing the wings come in,
you know,
and um,
we're pretty pretty lean,
you know,
like really want them to cook well and do fun things too.
And so they do have kind of an an an insane spread,
like all the holidays and all the special specialty cooking days,
like the kitchens go insane and um,
they're kind of the best days to be working.
I think people come in on their days off actually just to come in and eat.
Yeah.
So we do like,
we do the classics,
wings,
Blue Cheese,
um,
lots of chip and dip.
Um,
okay.
So I'm reintroducing the carrots back into this and I've really brown that.
Yeah.
Nicely.
And then,
let's see here.
Can you use an unslotted spoon?
And it really,
I'm just looking for like a little color.
The more color you get on these and you can see like look at their,
their buoyancy there.
You know,
they really hold up nicely.
Can you see that okay.
Back to the camera.
Okay.
So you can see this like buoyancy.
Really bouncy.
Yeah,
they're there.
we got a good bounciness to him.
Okay.
And right about this point,
I'm going to spoon a few of these right into it.
Yeah.
Cool.
Some of my carrots.
What kind of butter do you use?
Just a very plain unsalted butter,
you know?
Um,
and that's,
that's it.
We work with a local dairy,
so Petaluma out of Petaluma.
And um,
but that's our,
that's our goal with butter.
It's just,
just plain unsalted butter.
You can always add salt.
Um,
it's just kind of the cleanest version.
Right.
And then I'm going to put a little bit of this butter right over the top.
Don't be afraid of butter.
We talked about that already.
Air is thick with butter.
Scent in the room,
right smell.
Yeah.
It smells real.
Yes.
Okay.
So I'm gonna
take some gorgeous herbs.
Um,
so things that are very complimentary to character is mint.
Dill.
Um,
we have a little bit of wood soil.
You may see this around.
Um,
uh,
it's in season and it's wild.
Um,
let's see here.
First,
I'm going to take a little bit of this [inaudible].
I'm going to give a nice dusting it.
Then I'm going to add some of my pickled carrots all over.
Of course we want to show off the colors,
so there is kind of a a better,
yeah.
So I sorta smother it and pickled carrots.
And then I'm going to add some of my herbs switches.
That meant a little,
uh,
there's red veined sorrel deal as I said.
And then I'm going to finish the dish up.
Can I'm going to spoon over
the carrot juice vinegarette
and I kind of want enough with the vinegarette that it's like a sauce in the
bottom,
so where I can see it
and that's about it.
It's gorgeous.
There you go.
Cool.
Yeah,
it looks good,
right?
Yeah.
At some guys in the frame to hold back,
it looks and smells amazing.
I know that our team is working on some delicious tastes for you all.
Are there more questions while we wait?
Yeah.
Wow.
Ooh.
What's coming in?
What's future projects do you have inside scoop,
inside scoop.
We were actually talking about that on the drive here.
Yeah.
It's a good time to meet in the car.
There's no distraction.
We,
we,
um,
it's an interesting question and it's not easy to answer because I don't totally
have the answer and my mind doesn't really,
it's relentless and sort of the ideas that I want to do,
but I'm also like really about trying to build the most solid company that we
can,
that's got incredible culture and state bird started as 14 employees,
including Nicole and I.
And um,
you know,
we now with the progress,
uh,
with,
we're up to about just under a hundred employees.
Um,
both restaurants have about 50 employees each.
And,
um,
you know,
that's,
uh,
in a restaurant world it's a lot of,
a lot of,
um,
a lot to see and oversee.
And state bird is now six years old and progress is three.
And we're about ready for,
just start thinking about that next project.
I've been pushing back and we've had lots of really wonderful offers.
Things,
you know,
take state bird to New York,
take it to Vegas,
La,
Tokyo.
And I'm like,
it sounds awesome.
And it's kind of like the dream when people start coming to you with real ideas
and real dreams,
you're like,
yeah,
I've been dreaming of this moment my entire career.
And then you're like,
whoa,
back up.
You know,
that's,
it's actually like,
it's not as easy as that.
Um,
so,
and we have a lot of complexity built into our restaurants.
You know,
we have a farm that is biodynamic.
Um,
we grow all these little greens and a lot of the carrots and things that you see
in this dish.
Um,
and that's been an amazing project.
So we've been able to kind of,
rather than grow up,
we've been able to kind of add and kind of grow wide and create a lot of really
interesting pieces that add value to what we do every day.
And that has been probably the biggest source of inspiration to continue to add.
And create this kind of mega ship of this culinary building.
Um,
cause we're all under one roof.
within that project we do a lot of,
we have a whole fermentation,
um,
program.
I suppose.
We do a lot of Charcuterie,
we do whole animal butchery.
Um,
these things get done in our commissary kitchen,
which is just above state bird and the progress.
And we can take a whole pig and certain pieces go to state bird certain go to
the progress.
So we've got this really amazing kind of cat's cradle.
Yeah.
You know,
have a,
a matrix inside our own building where things are used.
This is one that we just launched with the cookbook is state bird seed and it's
a partnership with some very,
uh,
intelligent food scientists and restaurant,
people,
food people who all were all born out of a really high quality restaurants.
Places like the lawn tree,
the French laundry,
Momofuku a single thread up in Yawn Healdsburg.
Um,
so this is their first project under the render brand where it's a chef to shelf
kind of thing.
And so we're really focused on,
on this.
We're actually hoping that to see it here at [inaudible].
Yes,
exactly.
Get it into the mks putting a lot of pressure.
It's,
it's,
uh,
press.
It's really delicious and it's something we make and there's recipes for it in
the,
and the cook by now online,
a good eggs you can order through good eggs,
Molly stone's rainbow and by right,
both in the city you have it.
So there's three flavors.
We only have two up here,
but yeah,
it's really,
I'm going to start working on it as soon as I get back.
So that's,
that's,
I guess that's it right now.
The other idea is there,
I got to keep them,
you know,
people start talking and,
it's really,
I got to keep it under wraps until I,
you know,
Kinda,
until a press fail.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
yes.
Have you received blowback about like the not authentic desmosome some cultural
appropriation perspective?
I think like any restaurant in any sort of public entity,
you know,
you're gonna get,
you're gonna get believers and nonbelievers.
And I think we've had a good,
a good mix of that for sure.
Um,
you know,
me and the probably the first 18 months there was a lot more skepticism and
people didn't quite understand why we were doing it and what we were doing.
But once the ball was rolling and we were more publicly in the press and kind of
people understood what the goal and the intention was,
we haven't really had anything.
Yeah.
I
any issues.
And I ironically,
you know,
we never actually called ourselves a dim sum restaurant.
Um,
in the early days we've,
we,
we more kind of akin to top us and,
you know,
small plates and the idea of,
of kind of doing
like,
realizing that we're not dim sum.
I mean,
first we're serving dinner,
right?
I mean that completely,
you know,
challenges.
The whole notion of Jim's son,
which is a daytime activity and it's food that's prepared for,
you know,
tea service and whatnot.
Um,
but we actually have never called ourselves.
It's,
it's,
it's gotten to that point where other people have and we just go with it now
cause it's like why fight it?
Right.
That was about a year into it.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I think that,
um,
you know,
when we looked at the idea of dim sum,
dim sum was one function of small plates.
And if you look at Japanese Izakaya,
right?
Spanish top US,
Um,
Korean like Bond Sean,
all the Bond Sean that's on plates.
Um,
you look at,
um,
Mez,
you look at,
uh,
in Italy there's kind of this afternoon wine and snack kind of a,
I can't remember the name right now.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank,
that's it.
And um,
thank you.
Schaub you know,
we looked at that and we're like,
we're kind of a culmination of all these,
the French hors d'oeuvres party,
right?
Just passing hors d'oeuvres,
canopies.
We're,
we're a little bit of all of those things.
And we looked at kind of the Chinese dim sum model is just purely an efficiency
model of being able deliver food quickly on carts and trays.
We use a lot of trays,
actually more trays and carts,
but we've over the overtime have incorporated more of our carts.
And we've read,
redone our carts now and uh,
we do smaller carts that can do,
I can have oysters out and I can have,
you know,
a big clay pot at pork ribs or,
or chip and dip.
So there's a little bit of tableside activity as well.
But we,
we really look at it,
you know,
I mean the French have the same type of cart,
right?
It's called the gueridon and that's where your cheeses,
you know,
rolled up to your table cheese or bananas foster,
right?
Like some of the,
the table side preparations or Caesar Salad done.
Tableside so you know,
we looked at all of these ideas and kind of took what we thought were the best
parts and turned it to the dining room and said how can we serve as the people
best,
right?
We know that top us don't work in this country.
It takes an entire country and a culture of people that are raised from the we
age,
right?
Three to five years old going and having a little glass of wine and moving from
topless place to topless place.
Cause they all have their little specialties.
And the foods in the window there and you just kind of grab and eat right.
But when top us was kind of brought to the u s it was like the coolest thing
ever until nobody realized that there was a what,
what's the,
how do you deliver food?
How do you know it's enough food for the table?
How do you know?
Um,
you know,
a lot of chefs are taking an entree and basically putting it through like the
shrinker machine and charging two thirds of what the entree costs with giving
you half as much.
Right.
There was a lot of problems with it and there was no,
there was no way of uh,
I guess how do you break it down to the lowest common denominator so that
everybody can understand what they're doing.
And so we took that top us and put it on wheels and basically here are,
you're interested,
cool.
Six Bucks,
done,
move on to the next,
you're seeing,
you can see the portion size you can,
I can sell a lot of weird food if I want to write.
I can sell things that are like,
people are like,
I've never even,
I don't even know what you're talking about.
Like you're speaking a different language but they see it and it's beautiful.
Right.
And like they can vision,
they'll take it.
We eat first with our eyes.
So we basically took the functionality of all of that and took a type of cuisine
that everybody loves to eat.
Small plates.
Right.
I mean I hear it all the time.
Like I prefer to eat lots of little dishes versus like an entree.
I mean that is like you're all shaking your head,
you're all agreeing with me shaking in,
in agree I'll here cause you like to that,
right?
Yeah.
Bob Korean food is amazing because they bring out and kind of slaughter you with
Kim.
She's and tow Foos and cucumbers and sesame oil and Mung Bean sprouts and you're
getting all your little things and you're tasting and you know,
it's like you like all the diversity of flavors.
Well,
we just took that same idea and apply it a little,
you know what I'd like to call it little American ingenuity to it to make it
work for the American diner.
Right.
Because toppest doesn't work and it doesn't make sense.
I,
I'm confused too.
I ended up,
is that enough food?
And you got to ask your waiter and you know,
you've got to have this dialogue.
We're kind of,
you just want to do it yourself and figure it out right where you're in control.
So fantastic.
We are about to run out of time for our amazing live stream audience.
I know we have one more question here in the audience,
which we can take as soon as the camera's wrapped,
but I want to thank you officially for our full audience online and here.
Thank you so much for joining us today.
I hope you'll come back and see us again.
Yeah.